(tranquil music)
- This beautiful book is
titled "Klänge," or "Sounds."
It's by Vasily Kandinsky, who
was a very important painter.
He also made a number of
illustrated books in the early 1910s.
It was published in 1913,
but he actually created
the 56 woodcuts that illustrate
the book between 1907 and 1912.
Some are black and white, some are
in beautiful jewel-like color.
Some of the images are representational.
They seem to illustrate a scene.
The motif of the rider on
horseback runs through this book.
Here we have a much more
abstract image of three riders.
Kandinsky wrote the poems for this book,
and they have a very musical,
sonorous, onomatopoetic quality.
The title is "Warum."
The text is in German, it means "Why."
"Warum?
"Keiner ist da herausgekommen.
"Keiner?
"Keiner.
"Einer?
"Nein."
Kandinsky also designed the book,
the type face, the page
size, and the binding.
So for him it was really
a total work of art.
It was a very influential book.
It became a touchstone
for a whole generation.
There were artists who were
part of the Dada movement
in Switzerland, and artists who were part
of the Russian avant-garde in Russia
who would actually recite his
poems at their gatherings.
Kandinsky is best known as a painter,
but during these early years of his career
he was very involved with
the woodcut technique.
He talked about how
important it was for him
in simplifying his art, his style,
because woodcut is a very flat technique
and it has broad areas of form.
In that process, his imagery
got increasingly abstract.
So it was the woodcut
technique that actually
helped him develop as an abstract artist.
(tranquil music)